hello everyone and welcome to what is
essentially the DVD bonus features of my
youtube channel as you may be aware over
the course of the last two years I've
been making some short films and so if
you're interested in those short films
specifically in the behind the scenes II
stuff I have recorded a director's
commentary for every single one of my
films alongside friends of mine who
helped me make them so if you're
interested in saying that oh look at
that
tons of annotations you can click on
whichever one you want take you to a
playlist you can watch them all in one
go if you want to take your pick I hope
you enjoy them if you decide to watch
them and I won't stand here longer
because you've got a lot of stuff to
watch now enjoy